The animalist green party had its electoral debut in 2019.
They obtained 19,392 votes and won a seat in the Chamber of Deputies.
Now the one who will seek the presidency is Rita.
He defines himself as a teacher,
social activist,
anti-speciesist.
Rita,
welcome,
how are you?
It is a pleasure to be here with you.
Thank you very much for the invitation.
Just this one we remembered off the air that last time,
well,
that last and first time,
this one you went through our program,
had been a debate with the Valgueros,
exactly 2. 018,
when we were in the middle of the campaign with free
greyhound Uruguay for the provision of greyhound racing.
And in December of the same year we achieved the provision by decree,
fortunately.
Well,
that is to say a victory,
a social victory of the animalists,
it can be said.
And here,
here we have the animalist green party,
in this case with an animalist pre-candidate,
that is to say,
there is no green pre-candidate who is associated with it,
the environmentalism is,
and for the moment it is not defined who would be
the pre-candidate for the more environmentalist part,
eh?
What yes, eh,
definitely our look that is animalistic cannot ignore what care for nature is,
can it?
And the other way around,
I think the other way around happens too much,
happens too much.
In general environmentalism and
environmentalism with their differences as well,
do not recognize so much the importance of sentient life in general,
and we work a little more from the care of nature,
actually the Environment,
but from a point of view Environmental care.
But no, no,
do not be anthropocentrically,
of course,
It does not translate into no,
no, no,
do not embrace the cause of the animalists,
which is the most radical causes there is,
because it is really subverting,
eh, The focus,
no?
That we put to our problems.
I do not know if one of the most radical causes,
change is definitely at its roots,
because it implies recognizing ourselves as animals,
living with other animals in a society and socializing with other animals.
And from there comes the idea that the animal is
political and that it can be a great little starting
point to start analyzing the social without distinction of species,
which sometimes is what we lack.